Gideon's really good at navigating work
people and he like drops like jokes and
he'll be like does this building have
any like rainbow Flags he's like
definitely rainbow Flags otherwise like
I can't live here and then they're like
they're like oh welcome to Miami how
come you've moved here and he's just
like oh London had too many Rainbow
Flags don't nonchalant about it it's
just really impressive he's just like
walking around oh there's too many
Rainbow flags and I'm like oh God
yeah I don't like this apartment it
feels a bit matrixy and I'm like getting
like what like how
are you so nonchalant with these people
they sell him the apartment because it's
like the train is right there and he's
just like oh I don't take the trainer to
Matrix in the confidence that he has
with like on all these like
things yeah okay